welcome back to new rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and it chapter two was filled with
creepy hidden Pennywise sightings which
I covered in my recent breakdown go
check it out but the true horror of
Pennywise is his ability to hide in
plain sight in the everyday cruelty
human-beings afflict upon each other at
least in small-town Maine and one of the
biggest mysteries from Chapter two was
the character of Dean a young dairy
resident who gets screamed at by like
every adult stranger he meets and
spoiler warning if you have not seen it
chapter 2 yet Dean is oddly not at all
mourned when violently murdered in the
middle of a carnival what Gibbs I mean
small town skateboarders aren't
everyone's favorite neighbors I guess
ensure we are talking dairy here but at
least show us a carny stumbling upon the
crime scene yeah show not an atta one
but what if the inconsistencies in
coincidences around this kid are
actually evidence of a deeper conspiracy
that actually Dean could be yet another
sick illusion by penny wise designed to
dry build in burrow insane and paralyze
them with beer you can never
underestimate the lengths that evil will
go to smokescreen us with puppet
children so let us explore penny wise a
secret agenda in this episode of
recently some redditors have been
speculating a lot about Dean leading us
to re-examine this boy's role throughout
the chapter to story so Dean's first
appearance comes in the Chinese
restaurant as the adult losers lead
penny wisest horrifying fortune cookie
scare he calls out to Ricci who asks how
the kid knew his name the fun's just
beginning right
[Music]
well then the tension breaks as a kid
clarifies that the fun's just beginning
is a line for Ricci stand-up routine
he's a fan Ricci awkwardly offers a
picture deeds like I think I'm good and
his parents pull him away now obviously
in the moment we're meant to doubt this
kids authenticity proximity to the
fortune cookie moment that frozen smile
the fact that he's a child
but yeah it's a joke the kids got a
family you must be real but I gotta say
the reaction of the parents just felt a
bit tame like this adult stranger just
screamed profanities at the top of his
lungs right in the face of their son
while violently grabbing his arm and all
they do is like beckon their son and say
you okay Dean and then protectively
gently pull him away while giving Richie
just like a nasty look like he's merely
Arthur Fleck making silly faces for a
beat too long and real-life folks if
someone does that to your kid you're
gonna mama grizzly or like daddy silver
back over there and physically shove
them off and spring on the attacker
there are protective instincts that will
also make you crazy
so if Ricci doing this to Dean doesn't
arise and equally insane response from
these parents just saying someone should
probably call Child Protective Services
because that behavior is unsetting ly
normalized in that household but again
this is dairy no family is safe or maybe
this kind of armchair psychoanalysis is
why I should never be on a jury but
before we move on from this moment
notice Bill's reaction he averts his
eyes because bill more than the others
is painfully aware of penny wises
ability to take the form of a young boy
bill is just now remembering their
childhood battle with this clown which
ended with bill having to plug his own
brother in the forehead to get over his
survivor's guilt over georgie so keep
that in mind as we move on to these
second appearance of dean bill returns
to the corner of Jackson and which them
and he almost gets alert into the sewer
by it taking the form of georgie again
bill is able to pull away but dean the
same kid from the chinese restaurant
just randomly appears here - yeah okay
and in this moment bill transfers his
protectionism from Georgie onto Dean he
warns Dean that he has to stay inside
and Dean tells him that he's going to
the carnival later
now Dean here has a skateboard and he
seems loosely adapted from Stephen
King's novel there's a character of just
the skateboard kid who appears only to
bill a few times and one final time
after it is killed to tell bill that he
can feel the evil is destroyed there's
actually a theory that this scape were
kid in the book is a manifestation of
the great turtle deity michurin in
King's macro verse who watches over us
sometimes from t-shirts but notice the
bottom of Dean's skateboard here that
pattern is an easter egg snuck in by the
crew it's the exact same design of a
carpet pattern of the Overlook Hotel in
the shining
which Stanley Kubrick adapted from
another extinct King novel that carpet
appeared in the scenes Danny rode his
big wheel encounter the Grady twins and
of course the infamous room 237
the violent imagery that Danny saw in
those halls were ghostly illusions
designed to warn him and terrify him of
the true evil in the hotel which depend
on how you interpret Kubrick's story was
a metaphor for Jack's insanity and abuse
of Danny
similarly Dean could be a ghostly
projection designed to trigger bill
whether or not you believe Dean's family
was legit this second appearance could
be Pennywise changing tactics realizing
that Georgy is no longer an incarnation
of Bill's fear that works but a local
kid that briefly scared bill earlier a
kid that bill now thinks is real could
be the perfect false bait and that
brings us to the third and final Dean
appearance but before I continue thank
you to manscape for sponsoring this
episode because most frightening thing
about a naked horror demon charging you
is the untrimmed bullish wow manscape
calm is the only men's brand dedicated
to below the waist grooming and hygiene
they created the world's first
manscaping kit that makes the process
safe and easy their perfect package 2.0
kit features the lawnmower 2.0 the
waterproof manscaping trimmer for these
6,000 rpm motor in skin safe technology
no Nick's no snags no more feeling like
you're sticking your balls in a dairy
sewer and just hoping for the best
subscribers who purchased the perfect
package 2.0 get 25% off savings on your
order instantly a replacement blade
refill for your trimmer delivered to
your door every three months to keep
things clean free shipping and has with
free returns with a 30-day money-back
guarantee so if your bits get its return
that kit and for a limited time
subscribers also get a free gift the
shed a travel bag as an added bonus for
the peak high G plan you'll also get a
free mystery gift every three months
with your replenishment pack and if you
like a close shave on your face you will
like the first gift hmm actually for all
things bladed let's keep Henry Bowers
off the mailing list cool get 20% off
plus free shipping from your perfect
package 2.0 perch
winny is the promo code rockstars 20 at
manscaped calm okay back to dean
supposed a death in the carnival
funhouse
clearly this funhouse is designed to
evoke an association with Pennywise the
entrance is through the literal jaws of
a clown and inside the swinging clowns
are replicas of the Tim Curry Pennywise
in the 1990 miniseries now bill is alone
as he enters this funhouse who knows if
this is what it looks like in objective
reality or if this is all a manipulated
illusion by Pennywise designed to get
inside Bill's head and rattle him the
maze extends this distortion between
illusion and reality the way mazes often
do in horror cinema with Jordan peels us
and Stanley Kubrick's The Shining of
course getting lost in the maze
represents an unstable mind getting lost
in their own insanity and when petty
wise eventually does show up his form
appears and disappears with the
flickering light in fact when he
vanishes from one side of the glass
before he reappears in the same section
with Dean the flash in between shows
Dean's reflection in the exact spot
where Pennywise just was and then after
Dean's blood sprays on the glass we
returned to Bill's point of view and he
sees no corpse no Pennywise only his own
reflection and then he exits the
funhouse defeated and strangely there's
no disruption or reaction from the other
carnival goers no Dean's parents looking
for him hey because they're [ __ ] who
knows but it is clear that this murder
of Dean was a show specifically designed
to reach Ramat eyes the audience in this
case bill with another shocking death of
a child that he was helpless to save the
goal of this performance
Pennywise wanted this triggering
experience to lure bill back into its
lair in a weakened state unsure of
what's real and what is the reality
manipulated by penny wise in order to
make bill and the other losers easier to
kill perhaps the greatest trick the
devil ever pulled was convincing the
world that this kid actually did exist
perhaps penny wise his most violent
moment was a Terry Crews do you think
Dean and the funhouse was real in what
do you think we should investigate next
comment down below with your thoughts
follow me on twitter instagram @ v bosse
and subscribe to new rock stars for more
insane over analysis now if we could
just shake that kid a few more times
just to be sure
[Music]